so first I don't this gentleman and the
folks at Hills
College don't don't ask from
don't want to I can't stress enough the
integral role that they played in the
success of the school the support of the
students the support of the student
support of the faculty and the support
of the school's mission and vision so
for a few more words he's a much better
speaker than I dr. Larry P Arnn the
president of Hillsdale College thank you
all for coming here and for being what
you are I can say on behalf of the
college that I'm proud to be here with
you I'm proud to be here with Ben and
with Roger talking into the wrong
microphone if you didn't hear that it
wasn't very good
I've been pain is an inspiring man and
Roger who's about to retire from the
chairmanship of the board I think now is
the right time for us all to say boobs
you should know that the brains meant
the college has with this school is that
five cents or well never as much as that
will ever come from this school to
Hillsdale College why would we do that
we help to train the teachers and we
know something about the curriculum and
we want to be of support we have sent
our precious Kayla cash recent graduate
down here to work in the school and
you'll find that she's an inspiring
young woman and not so great as her
mother but why there's going to be
beauty here and the students are going
to learn that the expression Beauty
means the highest form of the term good
and they're going to learn what that is
they're going to look at the old books
that first talked about that a chance to
go back to the beginning when human
beings began to figure this out they're
gonna learn that they are something and
that that's something when it's
excellent practices those virtues that
they wear on their backs
and your mothers and grandmothers and
aunts and uncles you should know that
one of those virtues is courage and
courage is a hard hurt you it demands
that you do difficult things like the
difficult thing that you do and taking
on the raising of these young people
there's a sacrifice in that and a
commitment in that that makes life
harder and more complicated and there
are reasons you do that and those are
the best reasons in the human soul a lot
of you live in difficult circumstances I
know and I know that you work to
overcome those and the sign of that is
these young people that are here and
these young people are going to grow up
in those circumstances and yet every one
of them is fully a human being fully
capable of living a human life the
greatest public man that I know attended
school right in there and he was just
like one of these kids he was smart
he was young he didn't know anything and
what's happened to him he sits on the
Supreme Court of the United States and
how does he do that I have a privilege
in having known him before he became a
famous man he is a good man
he tries so hard to do the right thing
and that has carried him so far every
one of these young people is capable as
living as well as that man lives and
they have a right to the chance I'll
tell you one little story about Ben
Paine and then I'll shut up I came down
and walked around this school for a day
and it is true they don't know how to
organize events here so they think when
somebody from out of town comes in they
have to take him to a fancy restaurant
and I said to paint over there I said
are you not serving lunch in this school
today and he said well we are those hot
dogs they were pretty good and I said
well this is the place to have lunch
this is actually where we ought to be
having lunch today but they still
haven't learned what they need to know
right and they and I sat with the
students and I watched him talk with
them and I talked with them myself and
he's just I said to him once I said so
most of these kids grow up with
uncertainty in trouble right and he said
yeah and I said and that's got to be
made up for with their families can this
be done and Ben looked at me and said
well dr. Arnn we're here what are we
going to do right and the answer is just
like everybody standing here today was
it threatening rain we're going to do
everything we can and we're going to do
the right thing I asked you to help with
that it's going to be exhausting it is
hard to learn if you really
you know these kids are going to study
Latin and that's not easy and yet when
they learn it and they can all learn it
and nearly all of them will they are
going to be different people when they
have mastered that they are going to be
more fully human with every passing day
there's a world of blessings open to
them all it takes is some work I thank
you for doing that work and I want you
to understand how honored we are to be
able to help with it
Thanks